happy new year everyone and merry
christmas it is still christmas
christmas is more than one day it is 12
days long and of course
happy recovery from kovid which if you
are like me and most other people i know
you got over christmas and are now
recovering from yes the knolls family
like so many of you
celebrated christmas and the new year
with a full-blown case of the rhona
which frankly was perfectly fine in my
opinion because it gave all americans
one of the greatest christmas presents
of all
as kovids spread through the country
like wildfire among the vaccinated and
the unvaccinated conservative and
liberal alike the liberal establishment
completely changed its story on the
virus and the vaccines and even the
masks it turns out
that we conservatives we skeptics we
ordinary normal people
were completely right
about everything and they the libs and
the establishmentarians
and all the rest of them were completely
wrong about everything and we are
finally being vindicated in 2022 for
something that we knew all the way back
in 2020 before two years of 15 days to
slow the spread
i love my echelon i really do i hate
working out i hate going to the gym and
truly never do that but i love my
echelon because echelon brings the gym
home
when you want to reach your fitness
goals a lot of people are thinking about
that these days it really helps to have
world-class instructors like nicole
griffin and michael brown choreographing
classes with music from your favorite
artists you get a community of hundreds
of thousands of people who can give you
that extra push echelon gives you that
echelon is the affordable way to get the
workout equipment the workout community
and an instructor's motivation right in
the comfort of your own home with
echelon you can work at any time day or
night
crush your fitness goals we put the baby
to bed i'll go up and do an echelon
class you can do it 10 minutes 20
minutes to hour hour and a half it's
really whatever
you are
most focused on most comfortable with
you can obviously change it over time
it's great right now for a limited time
podcast listeners get up to 800
off msrp to get this exclusive podcast
discount text knowles canon wles to 81
8181 text null scanner wles to 81 8181
to get 800 bucks off msrp that is
knowles text it to 818181 message and
data rates may apply see terms for
details i had covid
i had it i know a lot not all of you had
covid but i had it
i had i had the real covid
we had a test
the test was positive
it was the real deal
i now am fully convinced as a result of
getting covet again and this test that
what i had two years ago before we had
tests was also covid because it was the
same thing except this time it was a
little more mild
the symptoms of kovitt as reported in
yahoo news this is from a study from
norway
they said the symptoms of kovid the most
common symptoms
are cough
runny or stuffy nose
fatigue and lethargy sore throat
headache
and fever and then to a lesser degree
reduced taste and reduced smell
meaning that the symptoms of covid are
the symptoms of the common cold or the
flu as we've been saying from the
beginning i don't totally want to
unders under sell it
it it was worse than a lot of colds i've
had
and and some people had it worse than
other i had it worse than some of my
other friends i've said on this show now
for months i don't think it's a good
idea
to publicize one's vaccine status
because we are living in a biomedical
security state where you can lose your
entire life and livelihood if you
if you
uh
don't go along with whatever the whims
of the ruling class are on the vaccines
so i
i don't think it's a good idea for you
or anyone else to publicize that you
haven't had the vaccine or you have had
the vaccine or you got 17 boosters or
whatever all i will tell you is
my whole family had covid over the break
a number of my friends all around the
country had covid over the break
some of those people were not vaccinated
some of those people
were vaccinated some of those people are
super duper coveted crazy and had the
boosters and or as gung-ho on the fouchy
advice as they could possibly be and i'm
just speaking anecdotally
there was no rhyme or reason to who got
kovid there was no rhyme or reason to
who got it more severely or less
severely some people who were not
vaccinated got covid the mildest of all
some people who were vaccinated and
boosted got covid really really bad
we were also told that children and
babies don't deal with covid as terribly
as adults do i'll tell you just
anecdotally
little baby knowles my son apple of my
eye 11 months old he had it worse than
any of us did
and so
i'm not merely saying that we were right
about everything and that the fear
mongers were wrong about everything i'm
i'm also pointing out that the elite
ruling class who have told us they know
the science and they're following all
the science and we have to trust them
they have no idea what they're talking
about and the things that they told us
about the virus the things they told us
about the vaccines the things they told
us about the masks and the mitigation
efforts they were just wrong they were
just bunk and now they are admitting it
the only reason that i'm prob i hope
this episode of the show doesn't get
taken off of the internet is because i
am now agreeing with the ruling class
and the media and the public health
experts and the politicians who just so
happen to have adopted the things that
i've been saying for two years where i
have at various times been censored like
like that lady in the comments uh
earlier said that sometimes the shows
will be taken off of youtube i i want to
point out the
what i'm describing is just an anecdote
right my experience of covid my family
my friends
but the plural of anecdote is data
okay you get enough anecdotes and then
you've got data and what we are seeing
even the ruling class say now is that
the reality of this virus is very
different than they told us it would be
i'm glad you liked that clip i'm glad
that in this new year
still christmas and this wonderful
christmas season you like that clip
go check out the whole show by ringing
the bell subscribing heading on over to
your favorite audio podcast platform
apple podcast spotify stitch or google
play wherever you get your podcasts type
in the michael knowles show it's gonna
take two seconds
subscribe that's a christmas present to
yourself
leave a five star review maybe we'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you